friederike schlingen lauf auf dem weg zu
einem 24 stunden dienst die 36 jährige
medizinerin arbeitet mehrmals im monat
als notärztin für das drk im nördlichen
niedersachsen
acht jahre hat sie am krankenhaus
gearbeitet bis februar 2009 10
dann hatte sie genug und kündigte ich
fand die arbeit im haus zuletzt ganz
schrecklich weil man gar nicht mehr dazu
kommt eigentlich als arzt zu arbeiten
sondern vor allem eigentlich zum system
gerecht werden muss und dem es darum
geht wie viel geld gebe ich gerade aus
der patient darf nicht länger bleiben
als soundsoviele tages uns rechnet sich
das nicht und ja es wird gespart an
allen ecken personal ist überall knapp
es ist nur noch stressig das ist
überhaupt kein lebenswerter arbeitsplatz
mehr
das habe ich einfach nicht mehr
ausgehalten fünfeinhalb jahre arbeitete
friederike schlingen lauf an einer
hamburger klinik in der herzchirurgie
wechselte dann zu einem kleinen
krankenhaus in die innere
glücklich wurde sie nirgendwo am ende
hatte sie immer das gefühl den patienten
nicht gerecht zu werden als modernsten
gelingt ihr das jetzt viel mehr sagt sie
auch wenn der job stressig ist
erwirtschaftet werden soll mit
krankheiten mit kranken menschen
das funktioniert eben nicht das führt
dazu dass gespart wird in den letzten
jahren an jeder ecke ist wird am
personal gespart an material gespart
wenn ich als notärztin arbeite dann ist
das eigentlich eine großartige freiheit
so für mich als ärztin als notarzt kann
ich alles was ich auf dem auto haben an
ausrüstung an medikament verwenden wie
ich das für richtig halte ich kann mir
auch so viel zeit nehmen wie ich für
richtig halte für den patienten als
notarzt habe ich das gefühl das erste
mal überhaupt als arzt wirklich das tun
zu können was für den patienten das
beste ist und auf nichts anderes achten
zu müssen
kurz nach dienstbeginn kommt der erste
notruf campingplatz ältere dame verdacht
auf herzinfarkt die notärztin versucht
sich ein bild zu machen
der ehemann hatte den notarzt wagen
gerufen weil seine frau über
brustschmerzen klagte schnell stellte
sich heraus dass die patientin außerdem
dement ist
der ehemann ist mit der situation
sichtlich überfordert sie machen ihr
bestes also das tkg sieht jetzt gut aus
im moment okay ich glaube nicht dass sie
ihn richtig akuten herzinfarkt hatten
aber wir müssen das natürlich einmal
abklären lassen
deshalb fährt das team die frau in ein
nahe gelegenes krankenhaus
sie haben glück die klinik kann
patienten aufnehmen
keine selbstverständlichkeit denn immer
wieder melden krankenhäuser ganze
abteilungen ab überfüllt wegen
personalmangel
auch friederike schlingen loch erlebte
das und das ist ja ein absoluter notfall
da zählt jede sekunde das kann jederzeit
lebensbedrohlich sein und den parteien
haben wir in der nächst gelegenen klinik
angemeldet und die nächstgelegene klinik
hat gesagt nein sie kann dem patienten
versorgen das herzkatheterlabor ist
abgemeldet und wir mussten dann in einen
deutlich weiter gelegenes krankenhaus
fahren und der zustand des patienten hat
sich unterwegs verschlechtert erst dann
reanimation split geworden wir haben
dann auf offener strecke anhalten müssen
haben reanimieren müssen sind dann zu
der weit entfernten klinik gefahren und
der konzern ist verstorben also der
jetzt gar nicht bis zum krankenhaus
geschafft und ich kann jetzt nicht
behaupten ich weiß es nicht sicher ob
der patient nun deswegen verstorben ist
aber allein dass man darüber nachdenken
muss ob er deswegen gestorben ist
das war nicht schön
zum nachdenken bleibt wenig zeit der
nächste einsatz ein verkehrsunfall
aber die zwei insassen sind nur leicht
verletzt und ganz langsam sanitäter
versorgen die beiden insassen friederike
schlingel aufs hilfe wird nicht
gebraucht
als sie zurück zur wache fahren bekommt
sie eine nachricht aus der zentrale
die dame vom campingplatz wurde vom
krankenhaus schon wieder entlassen
kurz nachdem sie dort eingeliefert wurde
das nötigste gemacht gerade so dass es
ebenso ausreicht aber kein ticket mehr
nichts mehr
wegen geldmangel wegen stress wegen
personalmangel gegenüber forderungen der
wenigen leute die noch arbeiten müssen
in dem system so läuft das nicht
auch als notärztin kann sie dem
wirtschaftlichen druck der krankenhäuser
nicht entfliehen
in einer bremer klinik arbeitet um
essbare arona gehringer tann für den
herzchirurgen beginnt der tag um sechs
uhr morgens
der 42 jährige ist in sri lanka geboren
und kam als 13 jähriger unbegleitete
flüchtlinge nach deutschland
hier hat er medizin studiert ist arzt
mit leib und seele geworden
doch nach zahlreichen stationen an
verschiedenen kliniken hat er lernen
müssen dass ein arzt nicht nur menschen
heilt ich bin ja nicht nur als mediziner
als arzt wenn ich dienst habt sondern
ich bin auch der das ganze managen muss
die betten situation und kommunizieren
muss mit der pflege mit stationen auch
ärzte in andere abteilungen wenn wir
keine betten haben
das sind mehr als nur medizin was man im
diensten
während seines dienstes im krankenhaus
dürfen wir drs wie er genannt wird mich
begleiten
es ist herbst und wegen corona halten
die kliniken jeden unnötigen besucher
von personal und patienten fern
für dr es hat sich nichts verändert 60
stunden wochen immer wieder 24 stunden
schichten und kaum zeit für seine
patienten moderne visiten laufen ja so
man schaut auf dem monitor um
entsprechend mit der schwester wenn die
schwester überhaupt zeit hat keine
sprechen mit den patienten und das darf
nicht sein und ich merke immer wieder
dass es einfach für mich persönlich zu
wie in die zeit ist um diesen
kommunikation mit dem patienten zu
führen und das fehlt der 42 jährige will
es besser machen
darauf achte ich immer dass sich bei der
visite den patienten - einmal berührt
habe habe ich den hand gebe oder meine
hand auf seinem herzen über ihrem herzen
teilweise gehe ich tatsächlich nach der
arbeit noch mal dabei und sagt hier
ich habe ja keine zeit sie hat noch eine
frage wie ist das ja anders geht nicht
ich bin ja auch nicht glücklich wenn ich
nach hause komme ich habe nicht das
gefühl ich habe den patienten gar nicht
helfen können
[Musik]
1925 deutsche kliniken kümmern sich um
die behandlung von kranken die kosten
100 8,9 milliarden euro
gesundheits fabriken die auf effizienz
getrimmt sind die folgen seien
weitreichend dadurch wird quasi ein
ökonomisches tribunal verhängt in den
kliniken
das heißt all das was man in den
kliniken tut wird nicht primär danach
bewertet ob das den patienten nutzt
sondern primär danach bewertet ob es
erlöse bringen indem sie fabrikat ich so
viel wie möglich operieren und jede
minute in den operationssälen quasi
ausschöpfen damit kann man viel geld
machen die ärzte wollen ja gar nicht so
entscheiden aber sie werden gezwungen so
zu entscheiden weil ihnen angedroht wird
das sonst eben die abteilung dezimiert
wird oder gar geschlossen wird wie sehr
ärzte mit diesem system zu kämpfen haben
kann man an der kinderklinik des
uniklinikums tübingen beobachten etwa
12.000 patienten werden hier jährlich
behandelt wir treffen die ärztliche
direktorin ingeborg regelung man im märz
2020 kurz vor dem ersten corona lockte
kosteneffizienz waren für sie lange zeit
kein thema am anfang meiner arbeitszeit
keiner damit konfrontiert worden dass
wir aufpassen müssen wie sich unsere
arbeit auch finanziell abbildet da gab
es in kaufmännischen direktor den hat
man kaum bekannt ich bin als erste
region 1997 wieder zurückgekommen da bin
ich erste mal wirklich damit
konfrontiert worden dass der
geschäftsführer mit mir die ganzen daten
abteilung durchexerziert weil der
kaufmännische direktor des klinikums der
meinung war dass wir zu viel geld
brauchen und zu wenig verdienen und das
ist dann wirklich zum damoklesschwert
wird ob man überhaupt nur weiter
existiert ist hatte ich dann erst vor
etwa zehn jahren so zugespitzt dass
immer klar geworden ist unser alltag ist
ohne die finanz diskussion kaum denkbar
auch deshalb weil die kinderklinik immer
wieder kleine patienten behandelt die
wochenlang auf den stationen liegen im
jahr 2018 waren es 350 mädchen und
jungen deren behandlung kostete mehrere
millionen euro
christel kreis lebt seit fünf wochen in
der kinderklinik um sich um ihre tochter
zu kümmern
das mädchen hat von geburt an einer
genmutation die impulse zwischen gehirn
und körper sind gestört daraus ergeben
sich zahlreiche folge erkrankungen
infektionen durch viren verursacht wurde
durch bakterien hat auch entsprechend
behandelt
dann sind die entzündungswerte wieder
hoch gegangen dann kam es aber zu einer
krise dass die immer noch einen hohen
herrn druck entwickelt hat man musste
dann in einer not-op eine externe
ableitung machen kinder wie emma
erfordern viel betreuung und ein großes
team von medizinischen spezialisten für
die behandlung von emma bekommt die
kinderklinik einen festen betrag von der
krankenkasse dieser ist festgelegt im
sogenannten fallpauschalen oder die au
dieses team nervös geworden wie man
diesen komplexen fall überhaupt abbilden
kann richtig genau und
das haben die juroren besonders im blick
da war jetzt da in europa und pda laufen
wir neurochirurg die ernährungsberatung
und gastroenterologie und der
kinderchirurg sie sind unglaublich viele
baustellen zu bearbeiten mit
unterschiedlichen experten und all diese
vielen disziplinen die hier zusammen
gearbeitet habe und diesem kind zu
helfen
es findet sich das in diesem system
wieder weil wir nur eine partie nehmen
können nämlich für die stadt infektion
kann man den anderen bereich nicht
abdecken das heißt auf deutsch gesagt
das meiste wird nicht gezahlt
der finanzielle druck zwingt die
ärzteschaft auf zu entscheidungen die
nicht immer im sinne der patienten sind
viele ärzte machen das so genannte die
system dafür verantwortlich die ard
steht für diagnosis related groups zu
deutsch verkürzt fallpauschalensystem
der dag katalog wurde ab 2003 eingeführt
und umfasst etwa 12.000 leistungen
beispiel die implantation eines
herzschrittmachers wird mit 16.000 euro
vergütet die operation an der
wirbelsäule bringt 10.000 euro kein
wunder dass sich die zahl dieses
operativen eingriffes von 2007 bis 2015
um 71 prozent erhöht hat ausführliche
gespräche mit patienten alternative
behandlungen recherchieren
dafür gibt es keine ziffer im drg
katalog und daher auch kein geld
ingeborg regelung man steht kurz vor der
rente
trotzdem hat sie immer noch damit zu
kämpfen dass die behandlung ihrer
schützlinge mehr geld kostet als sie
einbringt
der vorstandsvorsitzende der klinik muss
das minus durch andere abteilungen
ausgleichen
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 jahren folge
schließen wir weiterhin defizitär ab es
liegt nicht an den einzelnen leuten das
liegt am system
wir haben so von einem doch nicht
mögliches problem
wir unterstützen die kinderklinik die
jährlich ein minus von 3 millionen durch
die leistung andere abteilung gekommen
einfach hier auf keinen grünen zweig
sind sie gegen das drg system ein das
wir gehen jetzt in die volksabstimmung
ist ein sinnvolles system aber glaube
dass da nachgesteuert werden muss und
nachjustiert werden muss
wir haben hier extrem kosten die wir uns
einfach sehr stark belasten oft sind 12
kindern dabei die die einfach 200.000
euro pro kind ja mehr kosten als wir
wieder bekommen die bundespolitik muss
hier auch fettig versuchen mitzuhelfen
damit wir die entsprechenden
voraussetzungen schaffen appelle die die
ärztin kraege lohmann schon oft gehört
hat für sie zählt aber vor allem eins
da kann uns nicht dazu bringen
unethische medizin zu machen das ist
meines erachtens nicht mehr in die
grenze die man nicht überschreiten darf
wir fragen nach ob den funktionären
bewusst ist wie mies die stimmung ist
dafür legen wir den präsidenten der
ärztekammer eine umfrage des marburger
bundes berlin brandenburg vor
sie sagt unter anderem das 45 5 prozent
der krankenhausärzte
einige male im jahr darüber nachdenken
zu kündigen 14,2 prozent sogar einige
male in der woche haben sie das gefühl
gerade bei den jüngeren ärzten dass das
jammern auf hohem niveau ist weil sie
sagen das hab ich nicht mehr so viel
zeit für meine freizeit oder für meine
freundin oder meine meine familie
oder ist es wirklich ernst zu nehmen die
äußerung der jungen kolleginnen und
kollegen ist sehr ernst zu nehmen und
ich finde diesen ausdruck jammern auf
hohem niveau wirklich deplatziert und
ich kann die junge ärzte generation sehr
gut verstehen dass sie sagt ich kann
mich hier nicht aufreiben und 30 stunden
am stück tätig sein
kein bundesbürger würde in ein flugzeug
einsteigen wo der flugkapitän sich aus
dem cockpit meldet und sagt ich bin seit
30 stunden ununterbrochen hier am
fliegen und jetzt darf ich sie noch von
hamburg nach münchen fliegen und ich
wünsche uns einen angenehmen flug und
hoffentlich geht alles gut ich glaube
viele würden sagen ich möchte hier
aussteigen und im krankenhaus wird das
fast als selbstverständlichkeit
angesehen das geht nicht
neuenkirchen im nördlichen niedersachsen
im sommer 2020 betreffen friederike
schlingen lauf wieder wenn sie keine
dienste als notärztin für das drk fährt
arbeitet sie hier als
weiterbildungsassistenten in einer
kleinen gemeinschaftspraxis wegen corona
müssen alleine maske tragen
nach fast acht jahren am krankenhaus
genießt sie es zeit für die patienten zu
haben
auch wenn in der praxis ebenfalls die
budgets eingehalten werden müssen
[Musik]
kompressionsstrümpfe die bis zum knie
gehen
die rollen sich ja auch gerne so blöde
hoch und klemmen dann soll also ich
würde vorschlagen dass sie die man ein
paar tage auslassen die strümpfe und wir
gucken mal ob das ohne strümpfe geht ja
ok welche machst das schon oder haben
sie noch was auf mehr wind gut danke
schön
dies war von den link hier in der praxis
habe ich eigentlich das erste mal in
meiner ganzen arzt laufbahn das gefühl
dass ich wirklich so arbeiten kann wie
ich mir das erträumt habe oder wie man
sich das als arzt eigentlich auch
vorstellt also dass man sich die zeit
nehmen kann die man braucht einfach so
lange wie es dauert dauert eben also das
gefühl dass man morgens zur arbeit fährt
und total angst hat innerlich schon
richtig an spannendes und bauchschmerzen
hat weil man das gefühl das wird wieder
schlimm und ich werde es nicht schaffen
und es wird wieder zu viel sein das habe
ich seit einem jahr nicht mehr gehabt an
sich habe ihr die arbeit im krankenhaus
gelegen sagt sie jedoch nicht unter
diesem spar und kostendruck
zur gleichen zeit in tübingen im
uniklinikum herrscht mittlerweile der
korona ausnahmezustand strenge
kontrollen am eingang lange geplante
operationen wurden verschoben und
intensivbetten freigeräumt für
potenzielle kobelt 19 kranke
die landesregierung hat mit 150
millionen euro kurzfristig die deckung
der personalkosten und dringend
notwendige neuanschaffungen möglich
gemacht zum beispiel beatmungsgeräte für
die korona patienten 86 kranke mit
schweren verläufen wurden hier innerhalb
von vier monaten behandelt dabei fehlt
es schon jetzt und erst recht während
der korona welle an personal
insbesondere in der pflege sachen können
sie kaufen aber ausgebildete menschen
zwischen langer langer prozess den sie
brauchen und gerade auf der
intensivstation haben sie gleich mal
eine grundausbildung als kranken-
pflege- und dann müssen sie noch mal
eine zusatzausbildung waren da haben sie
die verzögerung fielen vier bis fünf
jahren bis die so weit sind dass sie
arbeiten können und vielleicht bleibt
als fazit von der pandemie übrig dass
man wenn der gesellschaft mal die
diskussion führt die wichtige chance das
gesundheitssystem
vielleicht ist das eben nicht nur ein
kostenfaktor sondern vielleicht ist es
eine ganz starke säule der gesellschaft
die zu führt dass jeder das habe ich mal
keine angst haben muss gleich an
irgendeiner krankheit zu versterben
das system muss geändert werden wie
sowieso wie sollen wir das machen kann
man darf man mit gesundheit überhaupt
geld verdienen was ich mir wünschen
würde
eine wirklich nachhaltige veränderung
der arbeitswelt
dann muss man so der rahmenbedingungen
der arbeitswelt weniger monetär geprägt
weniger geprägt durch prozess
prozesssteuerung und finanzielle
hintergründe sondern mehr etwas wert
auch den inhalt oder krankheit inhalt
bestimmt sag ich mal
es ist sinnvoller zu einem system kommen
wo genau das gemacht wird was der
patient braucht und nicht das
krankenhaus oder das system irgendwie
vorgibt
deutschland hat eines der besten
gesundheitssysteme der welt
die korona pandemie hat das unter beweis
gestellt doch es hat auch enorme
schwächen die mediziner und
pflegepersonal immer häufiger ans limit
treiben auch weil der profit mehr zählt
als der patient
[Musik]